the jurogan experience one of the most
bonkers things in our culture today yeah
and amazing that's that scientology is
like still
i mean i passed by the church of
scientology here just the other day i
was like
still works yeah they've just moved it i
when the documentary came out um
some woman had just gone to see it at
the movie theater and the
and the uh it was on the drag you know
on guadalupe across from
the university and she drove her car
through the plate glass windows the
scientology building
and she didn't stop there she drove
around the lobby a little bit knocking
over bookshelves and stuff
so she had to issue a statement
deploring violence in any form
was she a victim of it or no she had
just seen the documentary and she was
really worked up
wow so that's a hype she might have some
other issues yeah she might
yeah maybe scientology could have helped
her yeah
that might have been a course for that
well it's a weird thing when you see
so many people that are so successful
that are scientology at least you used
to see that
i had a neighbor who was one of the
nicest guys he was a great guy
he's a in my old neighborhood and he was
a scientologist
and i found out in the most bizarre way
because uh there was a piece of land
that was for sale
and he was talking about this piece of
land about possibly purchasing it
but uh he was gonna have to put it off
because he needed
fifty thousand dollars because his wife
was going clear
right it was like like a scene in a
movie where the record skips
and i went what like what are you doing
and this was
me of you know i was probably 28
at the time 29. i was
the podcast has radically changed the
way i look at things because i've had a
chance to
educate myself and have all these
conversations with brilliant people and
just enough of these conversations where
i have a different perspective but
back then i really didn't know too much
about scientology other than
i had bought a book from um
uh dianetics online because uh not
online rather
on on television late night tv 94
and they wouldn't stop sending me these
pamphlets asking me to come to all these
various uh
meetings and this and that and sending
me all these things for programs they
have and discounts and
i mean i was in one way i was kind of
i admired their hustle i was like this
is these guys don't stop
right like they just kept sending this
[ __ ] to my mailbox
i thought it was like a self-help book
and i would always been in the like
anthony robbins and all these different
i was into motivation like what can i
what can i
get that's gonna help me like work
harder or succeed
better do you know whatever so i saw
this thing and it was like
wow this seems uh very compelling and i
knew that there was a bunch of famous
people that were scientologists like tom
cruise and all right
i was like maybe this is maybe this is
legit and i was
reading it and i was like this boy this
is like seems
odd it seems off without getting too
much into it so when i
talked to this um guy who was my
neighbor really didn't have a deep
background
in understanding it but that was the
beginning of me like really
getting into it like talking to him and
and finding out like
how much money he had to spend and what
was it about
and like what did they do for you and
they he was explaining how
nothing would ever influence you again
no negative influence that's
going clear matt that was probably one
of the first times i had ever heard that
expression
i first time i ran into it was when i
was in college and i was
my girlfriend and i were living in an
apartment above this little
storefront and uh it was scientology
and uh i'd never heard of it before and
you know they
they showed me the the e-meter and stuff
like that and i just thought
i thought it was an interesting you know
i wasn't put off by it i was
you know i thought maybe so i didn't
pursue it
how old were you at the time i was 21
21 yeah and uh
you know it was i've always been
interested in religions you know it's
one of the
the themes i guess of my work and uh
and why people go into one religion
rather why they believe
one thing rather than another because in
america you can believe anything you
want
and you know it's not true in a lot of
countries but in our country there's a
smorgasbord
of religions you can choose from and if
you don't see something you know
you can make up your own and you know
it's a
very fertile religious culture
uh which interests me and
and i i as a reporter
i think about how people have strong
political beliefs
and it doesn't affect their behavior at
all
you know yeah you know a lot of people
like that i'm sure but
you know if you have powerful religious
beliefs it determines your life
and you know as as journalists we should
pay more attention to that so
i've always been intrigued by different
religious
manifestations and so scientology was on
my list
i had wanted to write about it and
because they're
you know they're always scaring
everybody uh with you know
legal threats or you know shakedowns and
stuff like that
do they still do that or have they kind
of backed off from that oh the people
that
some of my sources for that you know
they hounded them mercilessly
and you know they hire private
investigators
they're not they're not doing the the
job that private investigators
are you know they're doing is not so
much to
uh sneak up on you or you know go
through your trash although they do that
it's to intimidate you and
you know they had somebody following me
around for a while
mainly to my public events you know when
i was making speeches i
i'm in a band and he came to one of my
gigs
what kind of band do you have it's a
blues band we play you know texas
louisiana music
and we used to back before the pandemic
i
i don't know if our we had a regular gig
at the skylark lounge
in east austin and uh opening well i
want to come see you
oh you'll be invited yeah uh we got it
we're going to be really rusty
we need a lot of rehearsal now that's
to be expected so um
you got really fascinated by religions
and
what what made you focus on scientology
i mean there's
there's a lot of crazy religions out
there one of the weirdest ones about
scientology is we know who made it right
it's like him and joseph smith those are
the mormons and
and scientology the only ones where we
know who the creator is right
and the scientology one is particularly
weird
because it was a science fiction author
yeah it's like that would that didn't
raise any red flags to people
like well you know you you mentioned
mormons in the same breath and i think
that's
apt you know they were the most
stigmatized religion
in the 19th century uh
you know mark twain hated them
zane gray wrote a a novel
about you know how wicked they were they
were hounded from one state to another
and scientology is kind of the modern
equivalent of that you know they
and one of the reasons i wanted to write
about it is
you have these famous and sometimes
wealthy people as you point out
affiliating with this organization
they must be a kind of public relations
martyrdom for them
i mean you can admire tom cruise or john
travolta for
their acting but you also think are they
a little nuts
you know is there something going on
with them that they need this religion
and so why do they affiliate why they
lend
their celebrity and their
standing to such a stigmatized religion
that was one of the reasons i wanted to
write about it
well they must get some benefit out of
it that's what i
and they do yeah i'm not you know i
think especially at the lower levels you
know they offer courses like jerry
seinfeld
was in for a while i don't think he was
ever in i think he was interested in it
and he was studying it he took some
courses yeah
and he was never like committed as a
scientologist
what what is a scientologist i mean once
you're going to the celebrity center and
you're taking courses
you know i say you're a scientologist if
you go fishing once are you a fisherman
yeah that case aren't you
that's a good question i'm testing the
water i've played basketball a couple
times i'm hardly a basketball player
it's a little different is it i mean i
guess it is but i mean i feel like
taking courses and things does well
leonard cohen did as well
rock hudson i mean there were
a lot of people were drawn to it and i
think you know part of it is
uh scientology set itself
up as a religion
for celebrities it deliberately targeted
people like that and uh for instance if
you go to hollywood and you look at you
know
prominent actors and so on they tend not
to be southern baptists
you know they is not designed
for them and uh you know they may come
from a southern baptist
uh background but if they move to
hollywood and they're looking for a
group of
spiritual seekers like themselves and
they're you know they want to affiliate
with people like them
scientology says here we are and we have
the celebrity center where people like
you
you know can come and you can hang
around with other famous people
uh i think they offer a certain amount
of protection and i think there's some
something that there for that and
there's also i think um there's a
structure
that exists and i think there's a lot of
people
that especially in such a volatile
um sort of it's a uncertain world the
world of
acting in particular it's such a crazy
world i mean i've always said if you
want
the formula like why is la the way it is
well just stop
and think about what it is you have a
bunch of people that
move there from somewhere else because
they want fame
right and then you make them audition
which is the weirdest
thing you go into an unnatural
environment usually a conference room
there's a bunch of people sitting around
judging you and you want them to like
you enough to pick you
to do this thing so you can't in any way
buck trends you have to be like
uber polite you have whatever the
ideology is
that's accepted the general vibe of
hollywood you must
confirm to that you must conform to that
rather like there's
they don't even have opinions they have
this conglomeration of opinions they've
adopted in order to be led in
to this tribe and then you you
hope that they pick you and so you have
these incredibly insecure people who
want acceptance and love and then you
make them beg for it they're essentially
like going there and hoping that these
people will like them
and that's where you get the abuse like
the harvey weinsteins of the world
and these type of people it's like
they're preying on this
need to be accepted and brought into
this group in order to
to to be to to work to be able to work
you you have to play this [ __ ] up game
and so something comes along like
scientology that gives you structure
and gives you family and gives you like
the we are for you we're going to help
you become clear
we're going to bring you to the next
level you know you're you're a success
gives you something where you feel like
like have you ever done martial arts i
did judo when i was in high school one
of the beautiful things about martial
arts is the belt system yeah
because like you when you're a wipeout
and all sudden they tie that blue belt
on your waist you're like
wow i am making progress this is really
happening and you
feel fantastic whereas if you went to a
martial art
like uh i did kickboxing for a while
there's no belts
and it just feels weird like you don't
know where you are like where am i
like it's not it's not the most success
like and because of that some
kickboxing systems even muay thai some
weird systems have developed their own
belt structure
which is weird the system they've just
sort of added
to the existing martial arts that didn't
have a belt structure
but it's to give people this sense of
progress
give people scaffolding give people
structure
give people this thing where you feel
like something is happening for me
and i think that's one of the things
that scientology does really well for
these [ __ ] up people absolutely
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience